OKAY.
THANK YOU,EVERYBODY.
OH, WELL, LET ME THANK MY
HUSBAND, FIRST OF ALL, FOR SUCH
SPICY REMARKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND OF COURSE THANK YOU TO JOE
AND JILL, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
FIRST LADY JILL BIDEN.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US BACK.
THIS MEANS SO MUCH TO US.
WE WERE SAYING AT LUNCH THAT THE
GIRLS HAVE LIVED IN THIS HOUSE
LONGER THAN THEY'VE LIVED
ANYWHERE.
AND SO THIS, AS ODD OF AN HOME
AS IT CAN BE, AS WONDERFUL AS IT
CAN BE, IT IS A SPECIAL PLACE
BECAUSE WE RAISED OUR GIRLS
HERE, AND IT MEANS SO MUCH TO
COME BACK TO FRIENDS AND TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND TIME TALKING ABOUT
OUR GIRLS AND SO I AM GRATEFUL
TO BOTH OF YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING, THE LOVE THAT
YOU'RE SHOWING US, OUR STAFF,
AND THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
FOR THIS COUNTRY, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND OF COURSE TO VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS AND I LOVE TO SAY THIS,
SECOND GENTLEMAN EMHOFF, LET'S
SAY IT AGAIN, SECOND GENTLEMAN,
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY,
AND I CAN'T GO ANY FURTHER
WITHOUT, OF COURSE,
ACKNOWLEDGING ALL OF THE AMAZING
STAFF, FRIENDS, YOU'RE MORE THAN
STAFF.
YOU'RE FRIENDS, YOU'RE FAMILY TO
US, PARTICULARLY THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN PART OF MY TEAM OVER
THE YEARS.
I DON'T HAVE TIME TO NAME
EVERYONE, THANK GOODNESS, BUT
YOU ALL KNOW WHO YOU ARE FROM
THE CAMPAIGN TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO TODAY.
I WOULD NOT BE WHO I AM WITHOUT
YOUR PASSION AND YOUR FAITH, AND
ALL OF THE LOVE THAT YOU POURED
INTO EVERYTHING THAT WE
ACCOMPLISHED TOGETHER, AND IT
WAS AMAZING, HISTORIC, WHAT DID
SAM CASS USED TO SAY?
UNPRECEDENTED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU ALL MEAN THE WORLD TO ME,
AND I MEAN THAT FROM THE BOTTOM
OF MY HEART.
SO THANK YOU.
PROUD OF YOU, PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE, PROUD OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
RECOGNIZE THE RESIDENT STAFF.
AS BARACK SAID, YOU GUYS MADE
THIS A HOME.
WE SNATCHED UP A FEW OF YOU ALL
AND TOOK YOU WITH US, BUT FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WE COULDN'T
BRING, WE MISS YOU SO MUCH.
WE MISS YOU SO MUCH.
THE BEST PART ABOUT THIS HOUSE
WAS YOU ALL, SO IT'S SO GOOD TO
SEE YOU, AND YOU ALL LOOK GOOD.
SO GOOD.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
STEWART McLAUREN, OF COURSE JOHN
ROGERS, IT'S BEEN AMAZING
WORKING WITH YOU ALL OVER THE
YEARS.
I HAVE TO RECOGNIZE BILL ALLMAN
WHO HAS BEEN FABULOUS TO WORK
WITH OVER THE YEARS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND OF COURSE FELMA GOLDEN AND
MY DEAR FRIEND MICHAEL SMITH FOR
THEIR -- WE ARE WHERE WE ARE
BECAUSE OF THEIR COMPREHENSIVE
AND RIGOROUS WORK TO IDENTIFY
THESE INCREDIBLE ARTISTS, AND
THAT BRINGS ME TO OUR ARTIST.
OF COURSE ROBERT McCURDY WHO,
YOU KNOW, YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
YOU DID A GOOD JOB, BUT I GOT TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH SHARON
SPRUNG, AND SHARON NOW JOINS A
SMALL BUT MIGHTY GROUP OF WOMEN
WHO HAVE PAINTED AN OFFICIAL
PORTRAIT HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND I'M THRILLED THAT THIS
EXTRAORDINARY WORK IS GOING TO
BE ENSHRINED FOREVER AS PART OF
OUR NATION'S HISTORY, BUT
SHARON, IT WAS WONDERFUL TO WORK
WITH YOU.
YOU ARE A TRUE SPIRIT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
CONNECTED.
YOUR WORK IS PHENOMENAL, BUT IT
WAS YOUR ESSENCE, YOUR SOUL, THE
WAY YOU SAW ME, THE WAY WE
INTERACTED, AND IT SHOWS IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL WORK, SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BRILLIANCE, YOUR ARTISTRY,
AND YOUR PATIENCE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IN THIS PROCESS.
I REMEMBER I WENT TO SEE THE
WORK IN BROOKLYN AND POOR
SHARON, BECAUSE NO ONE IS
SUPPOSED TO KNOW WHO THE ARTISTS
ARE, SO HER STUDIO IS HER HOME,
AND SO SHE HAD THIS PIECE IN HER
HOME.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE GUESTS OVER.
YOU WERE FRIGHTENED THAT IT
WOULD GET OUT.
YOU JUST WANTED IT OUT OF YOUR
SPACE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND EVERY YEAR I THOUGHT ABOUT
SHE MUST BE GOING CRAZY.
SO THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GIVE THEM BOTH A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT IS STILL A
BIT ODD FOR ME TO STAND IN THIS
HISTORIC SPACE, SEE THIS BIG
BEAUTIFUL PAINTING STARING BACK
AT ME.
GROWING UP ON EUCLID AVENUE, I
NEVER COULD HAVE IMAGINED THAT
ANY OF THIS WOULD BE PART OF MY
STORY, BUT EVEN IF IT'S ALL
STILL A BIT AWKWARD FOR ME, I DO
RECOGNIZE WHY MOMENTS LIKE THESE
ARE IMPORTANT, WHY ALL OF THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
TRADITIONS LIKE THIS MATTER, NOT
JUST FOR THOSE OF US WHO HOLD
THESE POSITIONS BUT FOR EVERYONE
PARTICIPATING IN AND WATCHING
OUR DEMOCRACY.
YOU SEE THE PEOPLE, THEY MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD WITH THE
VOTE.
WE HOLD AN INAUGURATION TO
ENSURE A PEACEFUL TRANSITION OF
POWER.
THOSE OF US LUCKY ENOUGH TO
SERVE, WORK AS BARACK SAID AS
HARD AS WE CAN FOR AS LONG AS WE
CAN, AS LONG AS THE PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO KEEP US HERE, AND ONCE
OUR TIME IS UP, WE MOVE ON, AND
ALL THAT REMAINS IN THIS
HALLOWED PLACE ARE OUR GOOD
EFFORTS AND THESE PORTRAITS.
PORTRAITS THAT CONNECT OUR
HISTORY TO THE PRESENT DAY.
PORTRAITS THAT HANG HERE AS
HISTORY CONTINUES TO BE MADE.
SO FOR ME, THIS DAY IS NOT JUST
ABOUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN BECAUSE A GIRL LIKE ME,
SHE WAS NEVER SUPPOSED TO BE UP
THERE NEXT TO JACQUELINE KENNEDY
AND DOLLEY MADISON.
SHE WAS NEVER SUPPOSED TO LIVE
IN THIS HOUSE, AND SHE
DEFINITELY WASN'T SUPPOSED TO
SERVE AS FIRST LADY.
>> WE LOVE YOU, MICHELLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> LOVE YOU BACK.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED WHERE
DOES THAT SUPPOSED TO COME FROM.
WHO DETERMINES IT?
AND TOO OFTEN IN THIS COUNTRY,
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO
LOOK A CERTAIN WAY OR ACT A
CERTAIN WAY TO FIT IN, THAT THEY
HAVE TO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY OR
COME FROM A CERTAIN GROUP OR
CLASS OR FAITH IN ORDER TO
MATTER, BUT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT TODAY, A PORTRAIT OF A
BIRACIAL KID WITH AN UNUSUAL
NAME AND THE DAUGHTER OF A WATER
PUMP OPERATOR AND A STAY-AT-HOME
MOM, WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS A
REMINDER THAT THERE'S A PLACE
FOR EVERYONE IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE AS BARACK SAID, IF THE
TWO OF US CAN END UP ON THE
WALLS OF THE MOST FAMOUS ADDRESS
IN THE WORLD, THEN, AGAIN, IT IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR EVERY YOUNG KID
WHO IS DOUBTING THEMSELVES TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY CAN TOO.
THAT IS WHAT THIS COUNTRY IS
ABOUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT BLOOD OR PEDIGREE
OR WEALTH.
IT'S A PLACE WHERE EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE A FAIR SHOT, WHETHER
YOU'RE A KID TAKING TWO BUSES
AND A TRAIN JUST TO GET TO
SCHOOL OR A SINGLE MOTHER WHO'S
WORKING TWO JOBS TO PUT SOME
FOOD ON THE TABLE, OR AN
IMMIGRANT JUST ARRIVING, GETTING
YOUR FIRST APARTMENT, FORGING A
FUTURE FOR YOURSELF IN A PLACE
YOU DREAMED OF.
THAT'S WHY FOR ME THIS DAY ISN'T
ABOUT ME OR BARACK.
IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT THESE
BEAUTIFUL PAINTINGS.
IT'S ABOUT TELLING THAT FULLER
STORY, A STORY THAT INCLUDES
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN IN EVERY
SINGLE CORNER OF THE COUNTRY SO
OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS CAN SEE
SOMETHING MORE FOR THEMSELVES.
AND AS MUCH AS SOME FOLKS MIGHT
WANT US TO BELIEVE THAT THAT
STORY HAS LOST SOME OF ITS
SHINE, THAT DIVISION AND
DISCRIMINATION AND EVERYTHING
ELSE MIGHT HAVE DIMMED ITS
LIGHT, I STILL KNOW DEEP IN MY
HEART THAT WHAT WE SHARE AS MY
HUSBAND CONTINUES TO SAY IS SO
MUCH BIGGER THAN WHAT WE DON'T.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS SO MUCH
STRONGER THAN OUR DIFFERENCES,
AND THIS LITTLE GIRL FROM THE
SOUTH SIDE IS BLESSED BEYOND
MEASURE TO HAVE FELT THE TRUTH
OF THAT FULLER STORY THROUGHOUT
HER ENTIRE LIFE, NEVER MORE SO
THAN TODAY.
SO THANK YOU TO PRESIDENT BIDEN,
TO SHARON, AND TO ALL OF YOU
TODAY FOR PLAYING A PART IN THIS
DAY AND ALL THE DAYS THAT LED TO
IT.
AND NOW IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO IS
STEPPING IN SHOES AND DOING IT
WELL, SOMEONE WHO HAS DEVOTED SO
MUCH OF HER LIFE TO EDUCATION,
WORKING TO BROADEN T